well we are certainly paying more than
we'd like to for gas but how good is the
fuel we're actually putting into our
cars well it is a question the 8 news
now i-team wanted to answer we sent
samples from all across our valley to
get tested and along the way we learned
how gas stations are keeping this
commodity safe
with record gas prices
we wanted to know are las vegas gas
stations providing quality fuel
our project started with getting samples
from 12 different locations we took just
enough to fill up even smaller
containers to send to two different labs
each one sealed labeled wrapped and
packaged
then all our samples were off what do
you guys do in terms of the gasoline
testing it's primarily designed to catch
things like water contamination or dirt
contamination ryan stark is the
president of one of the labs we paid to
test your gas blackstone laboratories is
based in indiana they took our samples
running each one for water and other
deficiencies are most of the samples you
guys test
good gas
usually stuff coming out of the tent out
of the pumps pretty good
and that's what we found here's how each
sample turned out we started with the
green valley grocery on charleston in
buffalo
next we tested the funnies at galwin and
rancho
next the 76 at patrick and rainbow
the smiths at windmill in eastern
the rebel at flamingo in paradise
the arco at fremont in eastern
the sinclair near cheyenne and losi
the chevron at charleston and rancho
the terribles at west cliff in rainbow
the 76 at sahara in fort apache
the shell at twain in fort apache
and finally the sinclair at warm springs
in gillespie
we're in a dry environment so to have
water intrusion is very very unlikely
david crawford is president of green
valley grocery one of the largest gas
station companies in the valley and home
to two of our testing locations if you
had water contamination you're going to
have broken down vehicles and
you can't have that crawford tells us
why it's so important for stations like
his to make sure water and other debris
isn't getting into his tanks we found
out it's really hard for that to happen
so every tank in the ground is basically
a tank inside of a tank first crawford
showed us this panel which monitors the
amount of water in his tanks each tank
holding tens of thousands of gallons of
fuel bound for your car anytime that
number is anything besides zero this
tank is going to set off an alarm it
also will email company leaders
notifying them of an issue but there are
even more safeguards we're always here
we're always working outside crawford
shows us these filters in the pumps that
will swell up if they detect water and
the massive tanks themselves are sealed
and double lined and then the space in
between the two tanks has monitoring on
it so if there's any liquid of any kind
whether it be water or fuel it will set
off an alarm the fuel coming into the
valley is also not an issue two
pipelines from california and utah bring
gasoline to the valley it's then mixed
with each company's additives their
special sauce per se before it is sent
on its way to a gas station near you
that's why we go through all these steps
to keep the fuel safe ultimately we
learned most gasoline issues aren't
occurring at the pump
but are happening after the gas is
already in your car issues can arise
when someone puts water in your tank or
somehow sediment gets into your engine
take it from the guy who tests it it
can't happen but most of the time it's
in good shape and the samples that we
see are kind of outliers because they're
looking for problems and sometimes there
are problems in there
and denise brought up a good point she
said why didn't you go to costco and
truthfully it's because the line was so
long it was going to take way too much
time so there are professionals who go
out and basically do what we just did
and get those gas samples that test is
usually just a visual one looking for
water in sediment in like a clear bottle
coming up on thursday night we're going
to show you how those inspectors do
their jobs and how and when they cite
stations that's coming up thursday right
here on 8 news now